social entrepreneurship is an incredibly
exciting movement it was spawned Bible
drayton about 30 years ago who's
incredibly visionary entrepreneur who
had the idea that you could really do
venture capital for the social sector so
you could pick inclusionary
entrepreneurs committed to systematic
social change who had ethical fiber who
were committed to social impact who were
innovative and you could back them give
them some resources and a global support
system that allowed them to achieve
their goals whether it was in
environment education healthcare
immigration multiple different kinds of
areas of social impact and then this
movement rarely rocketed and what what
allowed it to do so was both the vision
and the power of a shoka and it's
offshoots like endeavor and acumen and
other wonderful organizations that
support social entrepreneurs but it was
also the massive growth of the growth of
the social sector so the the nonprofit's
if you look at the numbers there
dramatic between 1980 and 2005 you
basically had the number of nonprofits
in Brazil go from I believe it was
something like 5,000 to nearly a million
you had in the US the number of
nonprofits go from around 400,000 to 1.2
million so you had this massive
burgeoning of the social sector it
suddenly became a much bigger space with
much more impact and if you think about
it historically this is interesting
because in the 19th century we had the
industrial revolution in 18th and 19th
century at the beginning of the 20th
century and and with the and with though
the world wars we had the massive growth
of the state so you had the burgeoning
of the state but the social sector was
left behind and what you've had in the
past decades is a massive growth of that
sector almost an industrial revolution
for that sector now that creates huge
opportunities because you not only have
large numbers of organizations but
organizations that can work together and
have a division of labor where you
achieve much more now what's the next
wave for social on
trip ownership well I'm particularly
excited by things that go up the next
level so that helped organizations to
work together very effectively whether
it's collaborative technology
architectures whether it's organizations
like Ashoka endeavor an acumen that
helped organize that help entrepreneurs
to find commonalities Ashoka calls at
group collaborations whether it's
financing vehicles that go to the next
level that back a whole lot of different
companies and try to see or
organizations and see the synergies
between those and my companies and
organizations language is the other
really exciting next stage I think we're
going to see a whole bunch of hybrid
entities going from zero percent returns
in other words straight charity and
that's appropriate because why would you
know if you're trying to end slavery
you're not going to try to do it on a
profitable basis that is a rarely
charitable activity right through to
highly profitable areas like micro
insurance and microcredit where you can
do and other kinds of social business
like Grameen Phone the mobile phone
company that can be all of these can be
hugely profitable and yet hugely
impactful and I want to see a complete
range that goes you know minus ten
percent plus five percent plus twenty
percent plus sixty percent across the
board that works now i happen to be most
excited myself about the areas that
really bring profit and purpose together
and the reason i'm excited about that is
if you can do something that is hugely
socially impactful so is quality and
really helps people with the products
you're selling and at the same time is
highly profitable it's massively
scalable and I'm frankly obsessed with
the idea that there are four billion
poor people out there we don't have time
to waste we have to do things at scale
so I want to find mechanisms that really
allow for massive rapid scaling that has
a profound impact on the poor and that I
think is the most exciting
Arrowhead of social entrepreneurship
right now